infiltré à Auschwitz documentaire
réalisé par Ted en spa chez Maya yatagen
ou l'incroyable histoire de cette
ancienne officier de l'armée polonaise
vitole de piley ski qui va donc choisir
dès l'automne 1940 vous l'avez vu de se
laisser volontairement alterner à
Auschwitz avec un espoir fou parvenir à
prévenir les alliés du sort réservé par
les nazis aux prisonniers et créer les
conditions pour un possible soulèvement
à l'intérieur du camp mais à Auschwitz
comme ailleurs les Alliés resteront
larmes aux pieds jusqu'à la libération
des camps de la mort pourquoi que
savait-il au juste des pires atrocités
commises dans ces camps nous allons
maintenant poser la question à nos deux
invités présents aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau de débat doc tal brutman tout
d'abord bienvenue à vous vous êtes
spécialiste de la Shoah et de
l'antisémitisme en France vous étiez le
conseiller scientifique sur le
documentaire que nous venons de voir et
puis vous y avez témoigné tout comme
vous un êtes viv vous avez témoigné dans
ce film bienvenue à vous vous êtes vous
aussi donc historienne spécialiste de la
Shoah et de l'histoire des Juifs au 20e
siècle et je vous remercie d'être à
nouveau présence sur ce plateau de
débalox c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous recevoir dans cette émission je me
tourne tout de suite vers vous Vitold
pilevski depuis quand connaît-on son
histoire
tout dépend de le qui connaît son
histoire son histoire est connue en fait
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale puisqu'il avait un rôle actif
et à la limite officielle et donc
le rapport qui a été évoqué dans dans le
documentaire a circulé mais en même
temps et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il a très largement disparu été oublié
c'est que la Pologne devient communiste
puis il est ce qui fait partie de
l'Armagnac rayova autrement dit l'armée
nationale celtique au gouvernement
polonais de Londres qui va être liquide
liquidé par le gouvernement communiste
polonais et donc sa mémoire va
totalement disparaître pendant des
décennies jusqu'à ce que le régime
communiste s'effondre la démocratie
reprenne sa place en Pologne et donc une
histoire plus normale soit faite et que
l'histoire et la mémoire depuis le ski
reviennent sur le devant de la scène en
tout cas au début des années 90 puis
ensuite soit très largement
instrumentalisé depuis une dizaine ou
une quinzaine d'années par le
gouvernement d'extrême droite qui dirige
la Pologne aujourd'hui le pis donc il y
a toute une série d'enjeux autour de la
connaissance de la méconnaissance de
l'oubli puis de la redécouverte depuis
il sera resté 947 jours en détention à
Auschwitz les tensions volontaires on
l'a bien compris dans dans ce film il
sera prisonnier torturé et exécuté par
les Soviétiques en 1947 et ce qu'il y en
a d'autres des victoires
qui se soit évadés d'autres camps de la
mort d'autres camps de concentrations
en octobre 1940 quand
ce et interné volontaire c'est un camp
de concentration donc le terme de camp
de la mort est très englobant c'est à
grande concentration comme pour une
valve Mathausen et comme les nazis en
ont ouvert dans toutes les zones qu'ils
ont annexées c'est en Haute Silésie qui
fait partie du Reich comme le Struthof
en Alsace fait partie aussi du Reich
donc c'est un camp où on interne les
élites polonaises
les prêtres les intellectuels les
professeurs et c'est un camp terrible
mais c'est un camp de concentration et
ce n'est pas encore ce qu'il sera plus
tard à partir de mars ou juillet 42 un
centre de mise à mort où on va exécuter
on va assassiner à peu près un million
de Juifs donc ce dont témoignent
pileetzky c'est de la façon dont les
Polonais sont traités dans ce camp nazi
et c'est un témoignage
unique alors est-ce qu'il y a eu
d'autres évadés oui il y a eu plusieurs
centaines de tentatives d'évasion il y
en a eu à peu près 80 90 qui ont réussi
mais ceux qui ont écrit un rapport
qui c'est pas tout à fait un rapport on
dirait rapport mais c'est en fait plus
des mémoires qu'il écrit dans dans
l'après coup de son internement
donc le rapport est-ce que ce n'est pas
Rudolf Vrah et Alfred welcer qui se sont
eux aussi évadés en avril 44 c'est très
c'est très important parce que c'est
avril 44 c'est-à-dire au moment de
l'arrivée en masse des des juifs
hongrois et c'est à partir du rapport là
c'est vraiment un rapport que font vrai
que va se développer cette polémique sur
une action des alliés mais en 40 poser
la question c'est pourquoi les alliés
n'ont rien fait pour brunval pour
Ravensbrück des camps qui étaient
parfaitement connu puisque pour les
nazis le camp de concentration devait
terroriser la population donc ça a été
publicisé les contrecentrations n'ont
pas été un secret et on ne pose pas la
question pour les autres camps si on la
pose pour rechuit c'est à cause de ce
cet aspect multifonction
c'est une sorte de contamination
d'Auschwitz centre de mise à mort pour
les Juifs d'Europe qui va
contaminer en quelque sorte la première
vision de Auschwitz quand une
concentration comme dans tout le
territoire du Reich et vous faites bien
de faire cette distinction parce que bon
je crois qu'il y a un consensus sur le
fait qui est six camps d'extermination
je vais les citer un shelmo belzeix
Sobibor trait blinka auschwitzger et
Matt Danek et les deux derniers
effectivement étaient d'abord des camps
de concentration avant de venir des
camps d'extermination moi ce que j'ai
envie de bien comprendre c'est là on
parle de prisonniers évadés qui vont
donc renseigner la Résistance intérieure
qui est le même va sans doute renseigner
en l'occurrence le gouvernement en exil
polonais en exil à à Londres
quelles sont les sources de
renseignements dont dispose les Alliés
est-ce que ce sont seulement ce type de
source de prisonniers qui s'évade qui
raconte et qui font des rapports alors
il faut faire un petit pas de côté avant
de répondre directement à la question
pour une raison très simple à auschwitt
mais comme dark house comme burkhenval
Mathausen sont pas des lieux isolés ils
sont pas les quarts de tout et le camp
d'auschwitt il est à côté d'une ville
qui s'appelle à Auschwitz où il y a des
milliers d'habitants des Polonais des
Juifs jusqu'en 41 des Allemands etc etc
autrement dit ce qui se passe dans le
camp on le voit en ville tout simplement
parce que les prisonniers sortent
d’auschwitt pour aller travailler en
ville pour construire même la ville
d'Aoste les usines qui vont se
développer autour autrement dit on n'a
pas faire un Isola qui sera l'écart de
tout et donc rien qu'à partir de là on a
de l'information qui circule il y a pas
que les évasions qui permettent de
connaître ce qui se passe dans ces
lieux-là ensuite il y a un autre élément
c'est que même sans parler du
renseignement au sens militaire
l'intelligence si vous prenez la presse
mais la presse suisse la presse
britannique après ça américaine et que
aujourd'hui c'est très simple grâce aux
instruments de recherche vous rentrez un
mot clé comme à auschwitt vous verrez
qu'il y a énormément d'occurrence parce
que l'information circule même à
l'époque qui peut nous paraître
aujourd'hui archaïque l'information est
là ensuite évidemment il y a la question
de ce qu'on peut connaître en détail et
c'est là où il y a énormément de choses
qui annettent a commencé à évoquer
puisque 40 n'est pas 42 et n'est pas 404
quand quelqu'un s'évade en 41 ans en 42
il ne dit que crie pas le lieu que nous
on a en tête aujourd'hui qui est le
laoshit ce 44 45 et surtout il ne
décritent
un petit périmètre dont il la
connaissance parce qu'il n'y a pas c'est
il n'y a pas de vision globale c'est ce
que vous voulez dire non mais c'est
surtout un prisonnier qui s'évade il
connaît pas Auschwitz il connaît le lieu
où il est détenu à Auschwitz et à
Auschwitz c'est le consouche avec leur
bike Smart Freys c'est Birken now c'est
le camp de monovie de se rattaché à la
Bouna c'est une quarantaine d'autres
camps donc un évadé mais si on prend
pile des skip
il connaît que le camp souche et
d'ailleurs il appelle dans son dans son
rapport parce qu'il appelle birkenao
riceko qui est un lieu qui existe
puisque c'est un commando ce lieu était
par exemple
l'écrivaine Charlotte Delbo mais c'est
aussi le district où se trouve ces
endroits mais il n'utilise jamais le
terme de Virgin car en polonais ou
birkenao donc tu as la parfaitement
raison les visions sont comme nous
autres nous avons il faut il faut il
faut toujours un peu de bon sens en
histoire nous avons des visions
parcellaires extrêmement morcelé c'est
parcellaire morcelé et donc à plus forte
raison quand les Alliés reçoivent des
informations il ne reçoivent que des
choses qui sont partielles
et qu'il faut réussir à mettre en
cohérence ce qui est extrêmement
compliqué donc ensuite l'historien ou la
personne qui vit aujourd'hui à Beaujeu
de dire mais les informations étaient là
encore faut-il comprendre la cohérence
qui avait ces informations à ce
moment-là alors je vais vous citer ce
qui a dit Anthony haeden qui était le
ministre des Affaires étrangères de
Winston Churchill nous sommes au
Parlement britannique en décembre 1942
voilà ce qu'il déclare les autorités
allemandes ne se contentent pas de
refuser des droits humains les plus
élémentaires aux personnes de rage
vivent dans tous les territoires sur
lesquels elles ont imposé leur règne
barbares elles sont en train de mettre
en oeuvre les déclarations d'Hitler
d'exterminer le peuple juif voilà ce que
disait Anthony Hayden en décembre 1942
et en regardant en préparant ce dossier
j'ai découvert que effectivement
décembre 1942 à ce moment-là toutes les
sources de disent aujourd'hui
à l'image de ce qu'on a découvert dans
les toutes dernières archives notamment
en 2017 à travers les archives de l'ONU
les Anglais pour commencer et les
Américains savaient à la fin 1942 qu'il
était bien question d'exterminer les
Juifs d'abord ils ne peuvent pas savoir
avant que la solution finale avec des
guillemets bien évidemment été mise en
œuvre donc les historiens discutent
entre des dates qui vont d'octobre à
décembre
1941 c'est-à-dire de l'échec des alliés
devant Moscou jusqu'à par l'arbour
l'entrée des États-Unis dans la guerre
donc avant on ne peut pas savoir ce qui
n'est pas en cours
le
on se met en général d'accord sur le
fait que la compréhension par certains
par certains de la solution finale comme
un plan d'extermination vient à peu près
en août
42 de du fameux télégramme qui est
envoyé par le représentant du courage
Juifs mondial qui s'appelle ringner donc
à partir de ce moment-là il y a vraiment
en Suisse voilà parce que sinon les
informations comme disait tal qui
parviennent elles parviennent beaucoup
par des coursiers de la de la Résistance
polonaise
alimenter beaucoup par des organisations
juives notamment en ce que les notamment
la grande
organisation de résistance d'historien
dans le ghetto de Varsovie qui produit
qui qui informe la Résistance polonaise
mais il faut comprendre
moi je crois que la période convient de
vivre et qu'on n'a pas terminé qui est
celle du covid nous permet peut-être de
mieux appréhender qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une connaissance quand on est encore
dans l'histoire quand on n'est pas comme
nous les historiens à distance quand on
connaît la fin là on connaît pas la fin
et bon je serai probablement pas là pour
le voir mais dans 10 ou 20 ans quand on
fera l'histoire du covid on dira oui oui
on savait que ce virus était comme ça
parce que dans les archives voilà mais
il faut qu'il y ait une compréhension
pour quelque chose qui est inouï qui n'a
jamais existé c'est à dire la décision
de d'éradiquer un peuple non pas de son
territoire ça c'est un grand classique
mais de partout où il est ça reste
unique mais le discours de Nina il est
intéressant pour plusieurs raisons qui
concerne l'objet d'aujourd'hui c'est que
il fait suite à une faite par le
gouvernement polonais en exil qui qui
consacrent une brochure au sort des
Juifs en Pologne alimenté justement par
les différents réseaux de résistance en
Pologne mais il y a aussi un élément
c'est que cette brochure elle ne cite
pas elle cite d'autres lieux très
blinkia belzaix Sobibor ou les Juifs
entièrement de sont assassinés en masse
il faut insister sur ce point-là si on
parle de la solution finale et pas là où
Suisse quand concentration en 1942 à
auschwitt c'est pas grand chose alors
évidemment
dans les publications des des Juifs des
Juifs eux-mêmes qui décrivent tout à
fait en détail ce qui s'est passé en
Pologne il y a pas le nom
très blinka c'est quasiment près de 800
000 morts fin42 à Auschwitz c'est 150000
morts Juifs fin 1942 donc à Auschwitz
n'existe littéralement pas sur la carte
de l'assassinat des Juifs fin 42 à plus
forte raison à l'extérieur
du continent européen c'est là aussi un
autre point qui est très important qui
est évidemment on peut parler de Anthony
Hayden devant la chambre de l'ordre ou
du gouvernement
qui dès la fin 42 annonce 700 000 morts
juifs mais oui mais ce sont des comme
disait tal je rends série ce sont les
morts le nom de Balzac un peu esquinté
ici thé les gars et puis tout ça et puis
il a bien compris
les lanceurs d'alerte vous avez au
moment de la liquidation je mets des
guillemets on a tendance à se laisser
porter par le vocabulaire nazi mais au
moment de la liquidation du ghetto de
Varsovie mais
1943 le représentant du bunt des
socialistes juifs il y avait un
représentant des sionistes et un
représentant des des socialistes auprès
du gouvernement polonais qui s'appelait
soumaëlbaum se suicide pour essayer de
d'attirer l'attention mais c'est
terrible Varsovie le Varsovie ce qui se
passe à Varsovie c'est connu j'ai pas
envie de dire en temps réel mais mais
pas où je suis et en plus il y a un
autre élément très important on parle de
41 de 42 43 avec l'idée les Alliés
auraient pu faire quelque chose fin 401
les Alliés se réduisent à deux pays le
Royaume-Uni et l'URSS qui recule enfin
qui défend Moscou 42 l'Allemagne domine
toute l'Europe il faut pas l'oublier la
première puissance militaire du monde
jusqu'en 1943 c'est le Troisième Reich
il y a que deux opposants en Europe
l'URSS qui défend son territoire
national et la Grande-Bretagne donc la
question en elle-même est incongrue au
sens où mais c'est une question qui est
posée depuis des décennies pourquoi ils
l'ont pas fait en fait c'est une
question morale est-ce qu'ils auraient
pu dénoncer plus sans doute est-ce
qu'ils auraient pu changer quoi que ce
soit rien du tout fera une office des
Affaires étrangères britanniques
savaient
les États-Unis savaient les Soviétiques
que savaient-ils exactement quand on
compulse les éléments pour pour préparer
une telle émission par exemple on ne
trouve rien concernant les Soviétiques
est-ce que les Soviétiques s'avaient au
même titre que les Britanniques les
Américains et Soviétiques savent
parfaitement il suffit de prendre un
exemple qui aujourd'hui est très connu
qui lui aussi a eu un destin éminemment
compliqué qui s'appelle Le livre noir
des rainburgate grosse Man qui est fait
par un groupe qui a l'équivalent donc
des circonstances qui n'ont rien aucun
rapport du Groupe d'historien qui est
voté un évier dans le ghetto de Varsovie
qui collectait des informations
eren bourg Grossman est tout un ensemble
d'intellectuels jouent soviétique des 42
se mettent à collecter les informations
sur l'assassinat des Juifs en URSS et en
Pologne
et on a accès à ces archives soviétiques
pour le coup je crois que aujourd'hui
oui il faut bien voir que l'Union
soviétique sur ces territoires
qui se trouvent le plus à l'ouest
l'Ukraine le biais de russe les Pays-Bas
ce sont le lieu de l'ancienne zone de
résidence où les Juifs étaient confinés
et que c'est là qu'on lieu les grands
massacres au fur et à mesure voilà
et cela il les au fur et à mesure que
l'armée
allemande reflux il les découvre et il
le savent donc ils ont leur propre
publications
celle d'un moelled sur pied un comité
juventif fasciste qui a sa publication
qui s'appelle Annie kite unité et là il
y a les informations et tu as la raison
grosse Mann était un grosse manière
rainburg était que des trois très grands
correspondants de guerre
soviétiques
qui voilà donc cela on ne savait mais
quand on parle depuis le ski on passe de
suite et aussi il y a un décalage dans
le temps
à la fois un décalage dans le moment où
on assassine en masse les Juifs à
Auschwitz tiens les premiers Juifs
arrivent à Auschwitz en mars 42 118
slovaquent et je crois mais time je
crois qu'on peut parler à Auschwitz de
début d'assassiner en masse à partir de
juillet
1942 les convois en l'occurrence
documentaire voilà les les convois qui
viennent de France le premier mars puis
les convois qui qui viennent quand on
prépare les camps de Pithiviers
Beaune-la-Rolande pour
pour ceux qu'on va arrêter au veldive
cela quand ils arrivent il n'y a pas là
sélection c'est à dire que tout le monde
rentre dans le camp avec des conditions
de vie que décrit puis des skis qui fait
que il meurt comme des mouches mais pas
assassiné dans les dans les champs
de même c'est vue aérienne de la RF du
côté britannique et là nous sommes en 44
ce sont des clichés qui sont bien connus
des historiens et là on se rapproche de
la vérité là du côté britannique il
semble difficile de dire qu'on ne savait
pas alors en fait c'est pourquoi alors à
ce moment-là effectivement je vous pose
la question pourquoi est-ce que d'une
manière ou d'une autre on n'a pas venu
en aide pour certaines révoltes qui
aurait pu avoir lieu dans ces camps il y
en a eu dans certains camps ou pourquoi
on n'attend pas bombardé évidemment ces
camps d'extermination les chemins de fer
qui menaient à ces camps etc pour
l'histoire par exemple des chemins de
fer je pourrais vous renvoyer un
excellent ouvrage écrit par un AVC en
2005 qui s'appelle oGIS 60 ans après
elle va peut-être mieux en parler vous
alors et qui aborde justement c'est la
photo
mais la photo aérienne est intéressante
d'abord parce que il y a tout un
ensemble il y en a quasiment une
centaine de photos aériennes où on voit
à Auschwitz birkenaomonovitz et même
l'ensemble du complet la question c'est
pourquoi ces photons étaient prises la
raison est très simple les Alliés
recherchent des complexes industriels la
présence des camps n'a été découverte
sur ces photos que dans les années 70
par des anciens et de la CIA fin de
l'OSS mais en plus il y a un autre
élément c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut
réussir à trouver une information sur
une photo aérienne qu'est-ce que vous
cherchez quand vous cherchez une chambre
à Diaz la connaissance de l'emplacement
des chambres à gaz n'est connu que
lorsque verbat et vetzel remettent leur
rapport à l'été 44
a évoqué donc il faut réussir à relier
une photo aérienne ou voyez des
centaines de bâtiments comprendre que
parmi ces centaines de bâtiments il y en
a très exactement 5
qui sont des chambres à gaz et
comprendre que ça correspond à ce qui
vous a été transmis par rapport écrit à
l'été 44 le temps que tout ça puisse
être réalisé on est à la fin des années
1970 je rigolais sur cette question des
photos aériennes et compléter un peu ce
que tal vient de dire il faudrait rien
elles sont prises effectivement pour des
objectifs industriels pour les bombardés
il y a d'ailleurs des bombardements à
monovics et quand on lit les témoignages
il les témoignages sont états de
bombardements cibler sur l'usine de
ligue des Farben celle où a travaillé
Primo Levi
après la diffusion du feuilleton
Holocaust aux États-Unis 78
des pilotes qui avaient pris les photos
aériennes ce sont dit mais nous on a
survolé cette zone ils sont allés
regarder les photos qu'ils avaient
prises et là ils ont vu ce qu'on y voit
aujourd'hui mais quand on ne cherche pas
quelque chose et chacun d'entre nous
peut faire cette expérience dans sa vie
quand on ne cherche pas on ne peut pas
trouver ce qu'on ne cherche pas donc ces
photos aériennes on ne cherchait pas les
camps et aujourd'hui effectivement quand
on les regarde on voit
les camps mais néanmoins on savait
qu'ils existaient à travers les
témoignages qu'on a évoqué notamment oui
mais c'était pas le alors l'autre
élément quand même c'est que la priorité
pour les Américains et pour les Alliés
c'était de gagner la guerre voilà et le
temps de la guerre n'était pas le était
finalement contraire autant de la
destruction des Juifs donc l'idée qui
n'était pas fausse c'était que en
gagnant la guerre on mettrait fin aussi
à la destruction des des Juifs il se dit
quand même dans cette année dans l'été
44 dans l'été 44 on se repasse le
dossier entre américain et anglais on a
des renseignements mais on prétexte que
c'est pas un but de guerre de sauver
justement et cellules et c'est là où il
y a quelque chose d'important c'est que
c'est pas un but de guerre effectivement
on peut le pointer comme ça et en tout
cas justifier de cette manière là par
les Anglais mais en revanche c'est ça
qu'il faut pas perdre de vue c'est que
on appelle la choix mais est-ce que les
nazis appellent la solution finale est
un but de guerre c'est à dire que
hypothétiquement les alliés bombardent à
Auschwitz qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce
que ça arrête la solution finale il
suffit de prendre un exemple la ville de
Budapest est assiégée par les
Soviétiques fin44 irait 60000 Juifs
enfermés à Budapest DSS des croix
fléchés les Ultra collaborateurs
hongrois qui doivent défendre la ville
contre les Soviétiques
il tue 25000 juifs qui balance dans le
Danube ça c'est la solution finale c'est
pas l'objectif de la solution finale
c'est pas de convoyer des Juifs vers les
chambres Diaz down c'est de les tuer que
un endroit soit détruit c'est pas grave
on continue à les tu écoutes que coûte
c'est ce qui se passe avec les voies
ferrées il les répare et quand on peut
pas déporter les Juifs on les tue sur
place c'est ce qui se passe en France à
l'été 44 dans la région de Lyon vous
avez des centaines de juifs qui sont
exécutés parce que littéralement on ne
peut pas leur faire prendre le train
pour les envoyer à auschwitt donc l'idée
que n'empêche pas d'en mettre
quelques-uns aussi dans les trains
jusqu'au bout mais l'idée même que il
aurait suffi de bombarder à Auschwitz
pour sauver les Juifs repose sur une
centralité conférrée à un instrument
meurtrier à savoir la chambre à gaz on
oubliant que la finalité c'est pas de
les faire rentrer dans la chambre il y a
la finalité c'est de les tuer coûte que
coûte j'ai vu quelque part un individuor
que vous dit que les Alliés avaient
quand même une responsabilité
particulière vis-à-vis de la communauté
juive hongroise va appeler tout de même
que 437 000 juifs hongrois ont été
capturés et envoyé dans les camps de la
mort entre mais et juillet 1944 154
trains en 54 jours et là j'ai lu quelque
part que vous disiez là pour les juifs
hongrois tout de même
on aurait sans doute pu faire quelque
chose pour les œil alors côté des alliés
il y a eu cette fameuse négociation
d'Adolf Reichmann qui était un million
de Juifs contre 10000 camions enfin à
peu près
et qui a échoué parce que
elle a été rendue publique alors qu'elle
devait être une négociation secrète donc
peut-être
aurait-il été possible de faire quelque
chose mais quand on regarde le moment où
les Juifs hongrois sont déportés
effectivement les Alliés ont déjà
débarqué en Italie en
Normandie les l'Armée rouge avancent à
grands pas donc la tragédie des chiffons
hongrois a lieu vraiment à la fin de la
guerre mais en même temps
à partir de juillet 1944
la menace qui est faite à orties va
stopper aussi donc on est toujours avec
cette histoire à se dire ben voilà on a
déporté tous les juifs de Hongrie sauf
ce Budapest qui ont été assassinés comme
tal
la rappeler tout à l'heure voilà mais je
pense quand même que à partir du moment
où
la guerre est déclarée
les Juifs globalement sont quand même
pris dans la nasse et que la
responsabilité alliée principale elle
est d'avant la guerre d'avoir laissé
s'installer ce régime nazi et d'avoir
fermé très largement
toute possibilité pour les Juifs de
migrer dans
dans le reste du monde donc peut-être un
manque d'anticipation aussi du côté ou
non volonté politique tout simplement
le vicomte camborne membre du
gouvernement lui aussi de Winston
Churchill alors là nous sommes en mai 43
et qui déclare que le Royaume-Uni avait
déjà trop accu de réfugiés il pouvait
accorder de statut spécial pour les
Juifs demandant l'asile là nous sommes
en 43 les Britanniques n'ont rien fait
pour accepter
ils ne veulent pas de européenne pour
leur envoyer c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut comprendre aujourd'hui de la même
manière que les États-Unis au même
moment vont refuser accueillir des Juifs
qui essaient de fuir l'Europe vaille que
vaille mais alors c'est hautement
symbolique et donc ça pointe évidemment
en matière de responsabilité mais en
même temps qu'il s'agisse du Royaume-Uni
ou des États-Unis en 43-44 on parle de
centaines ou de quelques milliers de
personnes il faut bien comprendre que
quand ces événements là se déroulent le
plus gros de la solution finale est
achevé il y a déjà pratiquement 5
millions de Juifs qui ont été assassinés
et donc c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
insister et ça n'exonère en rien à net
la rappeler la responsabilité des
démocraties avant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale mais la solution finale est un
objectif militaire de la première
puissance militaire du monde quand elle
est déclenchée quand à partir de l'été
41 en URSS puis ensuite fin 41 quand le
plan était élargi à l'ensemble du
territoire européen pour aller vite
l'Allemagne contrôle toute l'Europe
l'Allemagne a la première puissance
militaire du monde elle fait ce qu'elle
veut personne ne peut s'y opposer et
elle réussit son projet ça c'est le
constat froid de ce qui s'est déroulé
est-ce que les Alliés auraient pu
protester publiquement davantage
évidemment que oui est-ce que ça aurait
changé quelque chose certainement pas
et il faut voir aussi que toutes ces
polémiques
sur le bombardement d'Auschwitz c'est
une polémique qui est très tardive qui
vient d'un article d'un des grands
historiens Weiman qui avait écrit
l'abandon des Juifs donc c'est des
polémiques des années 70 la polémique
sur le silence du pape elle vient de la
pièce de
route qui s'appelle le vicaire dans les
jusqu'à la fin des années 60 personnes
ne met en cause le rôle de pidouze donc
il y a il y a des il y a un certain
nombre de polémiques sur à la fois le
silence pourquoi est-ce qu'on a rien dit
et l'inaction pourquoi on n'a rien fait
qui sont des polémiques un peu tardives
dernier point je vous l'aborderai avec
vous c'est la dernière minute et vous
aurez sans doute le mot de la fin
vitoleski dans ce film on nous explique
qu'il aurait souhaité une
insurrection intérieure ou quand et il
avait préparé les choses pour ça
visiblement c'est ce qui nous est dit
dans dans ce film il y a eu des révoltes
il y en a eu à attribblinka ou 43
Sobibor octobre 43 Auschwitz
7 octobre 44 elles n'ont pas été au bout
cérévolte elles ont été l'énergie du
désespoir ces révolte il n'y avait pas
là aussi un espoir que en se révoltant à
l'intérieur des camps peut-être qu'une
forme de résistance aurait pu intervenir
pour
les trois révoltes que vous venez de
mentionner elle se déroule pas dans les
camps de concentration mais dans les
centres de mise à mort y compris celle
du Thunder commando en octobre 44 à
Auschwitz pour une raison qui est
relativement simple horizon d'attente
d'espérance n'est pas le même les Juifs
qui sont à très bienka ou qui sont dans
le centre de mise à mort d'Auschwitz
savent qu'ils sont condamnés à très
brève échéance un détenu de camps de
concentration malgré l'immense violence
qui règne peut escompté survivre le
lendemain puis le surlendemain c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe avec la
révolte du vendeur commando la
résistance à l'intérieur du camp de
concentration dauschwitz qui est en
contact avec eux leur dit attendez les
Alliés approchent nous allons peut-être
être libéré et le Ender commando lui n'a
pas le choix parce qu'il condamné donc
il y a des logiques différentes et
également des sorts différents dans des
lieux qui sont pas des lieux uniques ce
sera le mot de la fin merci un grand
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à ce débat doc aujourd'hui avec notre
documentaire infiltré à Auschwitz et
puis vos commentaires vous explications
votre décryptage autour de cette
question que savait les alliés des camps
de la mort vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débat doc bien sûr sur Twitter
merci à Selma Sally qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission je donne un rendez-vous pour un
prochain débat doc ça sera la même place
la même heure et toujours avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]